what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and
before we start this video I just wanna
let you guys know I can't really go into
any detail about it but there is a
there's something coming down the line
that's gonna be pretty awesome
assuming that it all goes well and it
goes it goes the way that I would want
you it's gonna be pretty damn awesome
it'll be the greatest honor this channel
has had since its inception it'll be
pretty sweet but in this video I want to
talk about I want to cover this this
Batman one-shot so Batman comic City
most people know this by now but that
make how much are always usually dark
and brooding and every once in a while
you need a story that can break the
monotony that's really kind of the
essential thing about Batman comics you
need a story that's able to break away
from being so dark and and make things
interesting and intriguing and so in
this one we're covering the return of a
few characters crazy quilt and of course
economy King and it's kind of told it
like a series of flashbacks and it's a
really really cool moment here because
it focuses a lot on Dick Grayson and and
really it focuses on Dick Grayson and
his relationship to Bruce Wayne and this
is kind of an important thing because
one of the things to bear in mind with
DC rebirth that's one of reasons why
what DC is doing right now is so
effective is because this is the the
jumping on platform for a lot of people
and so for a lot of people who are
getting into DC Comics they haven't been
reading for 20 years 25 years 30 years
or even you know as many as 40 or 50
years depending on how old you know you
might be if you're watching this video
and so with this being the new point for
them is really kind of difficult to sort
of imagine what things were like with
Dick Grayson when he was a kid and he
was brought in by Bruce Wayne and so
what this does is this basically picks
up with crazy quilt and crazy quilt is
exactly what you would expect a crazy
guy in a quilt and it is it's hilarious
because you have Dick Grayson who's
watching this whole thing unfold is
Nightwing and he's just kind of like
wait so so what's this guy's deal this
guy does this guy does what now and the
guys kind of going on and he's like he's
like I have my quilt of colors and with
these colors I will hypnotize you and
you will bend to my whim and the whole
time the guy's just a goof right he
looks like a character directly out of
like like the old Adam West Batman show
and no one takes him seriously but like
he wants to be taken seriously right
like the whole time he's like mine
you're going to be mine and dig
Grayson's like hung up on this idea that
this guy has like a fetish for like
quilting but this guy is like a B or C
or like a like a a G List villain at
best like this
that's the best he could ever possibly
be and it's kind of funny cuz he's like
what I admit these colors you're going
to bend to my whim and diction decreases
responses well maybe we'll just like
close our eyes and then just like beat
the crap out of you while all that's
going on it's kind of a funny little
moment here because this is like old
school Batman's storytelling right like
this is like nineteen 1960s Batman meets
like the modern a modern age characters
right like you take a story from like
the from back in the 60s and you say
what would happen if this story was
written does the story was written in
the 60s was written now but it contained
the versions of the characters that we
know now as opposed to the ones that we
knew back then that were silly and goofy
and this is what you'll get the other
half of this is kind of jumping to the
flashback
when Dick Grayson was taken in by Bruce
following the death of his parents and
one of the big misconceptions people
have is that at the outset that it was
just kind of like a new home and
everything was swell the cool thing
about this is that it shows that it's
not that Dick Grayson didn't want to be
there Dick Grayson didn't like Bruce
Wayne he didn't he didn't like not being
home now in reality it's him just kind
of lashing out in an environment that
he's not wildly familiar with that he
that there for him it's not his home and
it's one of those things works like I
want to go back home I want to go back
and see my parents but in truth Dick
Grayson knows as a kid there's no coming
back from that he's crossed a line that
he can't come back from his parents are
dead and all he has now is Bruce Wayne
and so kind of lashing out in that
regard is is so intriguing because when
you look at dick himself when you look
at Dick Grayson himself one of the
things that people that a lot of newer
readers don't really realize is that
Dick Grayson is one of those characters
that like all the superheroes in the DC
Universe know and love they like
everybody likes Dick Grayson because in
a world of darker heroes you know really
with the exception of Superman dick
Grayson's like the bright shining star
of the superhero community and so when
it comes to this whole thing that's why
I did Grayson is so popular because he's
the one guy that just keeps on looking
and believing well things will just get
better he's a great compliment to the
character of Bruce and so from here
there's this instance is this really
really great moment when Bruce Wayne and
Alfred go to feed lunch today Grayson
in-degree you know they're like hey
here's a here's cucumber sandwiches and
Dick Grayson hates them now he doesn't
really know how to come to grips with
this situation that his life has changed
irrevocably as we just kind of lashes
out this hopefully sucks this whole
place stinks I don't like this place and
it's kind of interesting because it's
designed to sort of compare where he was
in relation to Bruce to where he is now
and this is when we transition economy
came now as anybody will tell you
condiment King is probably the greatest
villain ever created in the history of
comic books the question is why because
he is a
that literally shoots you with
condiments he shoots you with like
ketchup and mustard and like I mean he's
killed people before but like he's
amazing dude I love condiment King do
condiment King is so cool
do I love condiment King Batman the
Animated Series I love condiment that's
were like 99.999% of people who have
heard of his character heard of him from
was Batman the Animated Series when he
was just like running around with these
little guns that shot like ketchup and
mustard it was kind of cool of course
you didn't shoot mayonnaise because most
anybody will tell you manning sucks but
like like it's cool to see this whole
thing you know like like it's it's
interesting here I mean now of course
there are rules here I mean condiment
King as well he will tell you you know
that that is reasonable to make the
statement that mustard goes on hotdogs
and ketchup goes on hamburgers we know
that as a universal truth right you
never put on a hamburger you never put
ketchup and mustard on a hamburger you
don't do that it doesn't work that way
you know it's like putting pineapple on
on pizza it's just something you don't
do you could but then at that point we
have to exile you from society and so
this funny thing condiment man like hits
him in the face hits decoration in the
face with a tomato and then that's when
Dick Grayson gets pissed but it's one of
these things were like Batman's dark and
brooding all the time and Dick Grayson's
idea is do you just kind of have to
laugh through once while you have to let
loose you have to cry every once in a
while man you can't be upset all the
time you don't honestly this is
condiment King man he's not to do that
you take seriously in Batman's like oh
yes he is
he's killed people and stuff it's like
yeah but like the guy shoots condiments
at you how could you possibly take this
seriously as it was kind of a funny
thing because kind of jumping back to
the past again it's another scenario
where Dick Grayson doesn't really
doesn't really like being in Wayne Manor
but the longer he's there and the more
he comes to grips with the fact that he
can't go back the more he begins to
accept it and in this acceptance he
begins to find a middle ground with
Bruce Wayne where he goes through and
tries to like swing tries to treat his
chandelier like a trapeze and it comes
crashing to the ground his responses
will AMA flying Grayson that's what
flying Grayson's do and so with with
Bruce trying to talk to him and trying
to reason with him the idea of Bruce was
to approach him more as like a guardian
of sorts as opposed to trying to relate
but when Bruce does start to relate
that's when he starts to open up when he
says look I lost my parents too and
maybe we can talk about this and come to
terms together so we can understand
where the others coming from that's the
switch that's the moment where
everything begins to shift for dick and
he begins to look at Bruce Wayne as a
father
but it is interesting here because we're
the father of Bruce was by all standards
of measurement in terms of comic book
storytelling a great father Bruce is
very closed off he's very shut off and
he doesn't really know how to open
himself up to other people and so for
him this is much as much of a big of a
step for Bruce as it is for the
character of Dick Grayson and that's why
if I'm being honest here that's why I
did Grayson I would argue it's probably
the single most important character in
the Batman mythos while Alfred is Bruce
Wayne's voice is his conscience his
voice of reason in the back of his head
saying you probably shouldn't do that
Dick Grayson is the one that makes him
human and that's what's so cool that
that's that's what's so interesting he's
the one that kind of anchors Bruce Wayne
to reality and you see it manifest every
once in a while like we saw that was the
death of Jason Todd right you know death
in the family Jason Todd dies and then
Batman begins to go on this this crazy
scenario he begins to lose his mind and
become more and more extreme and when
Tim Drake begins to realize or basically
picks up on the fact that Bruce is
Batman and Dick Grayson is Robin he goes
to Dick Grayson and says you have to
stop being on Nightwing and you have to
go back to being Robin that's the one he
approaches now the other reason for that
is because Jason Todd was the only other
arm besides Dick Grayson at the time but
it still makes sense that like he would
go to him and say you have to anchor him
back you have to bring him back here and
help them rediscover who he needs to be
and even like these these scenarios
where Dick Grayson sitting on a couch
and he's watching a football game when
Bruce Wayne sits down he's always kind
of like distant Batman doesn't really
seem to be human he seems more like he
seems more alien than like Superman
anything that makes us a human like
laughing and joking and being in love
and all his guns left Bruce Wayne
doesn't have any of those things
and so when Dick Grayson is sitting down
and he's talking to him dick Grayson's
like yeah man let's watch the game dude
let's check out the game and Bruce is
just kinda like yeah but we have stuff
to do but it's not even it doesn't even
put off the air of like a human saying
that it's like a robot saying that it's
Hamid Khan saying that and then we end
up finding out the idea of the chips of
Dick Grayson's eating and the reason why
he and Bruce share them is because
that's when they really began to sort of
mend this rift that when Dick Grayson
was a kid all he wanted was potato chips
now of course as we know Alfred is like
the only real responsible human being in
Wayne Manor and so he's kind of they do
like the kid can't eat nothing but
potato chips all the time and so Bruce
is like what like he likes potato chips
though and I was like yeah but he needs
a meal it's like yeah but like he likes
chips so like let the kid have chips let
the kid eat some chips and so it's a
funny moment is it's a great touch
a great way to sort of show how these
two characters came together you know
how these two guys begin to relate and
Batman kind of lets his guard down for a
second when Dick Grayson is going
through and he's like hey I'm gonna
bounce this thing off you know 37 times
or whatever it is I'm gonna make a bet
you know I bet you a penny that I can do
it you know Batman kind of goes along
with it it's like I don't really bet but
you know okay whatever
Dick Grayson pulls it off and Batman
Neal kind of laughs for a second and
then he starts to cry and it's like it's
like you know and as soon as that
happens the mask immediately comes back
on and as Ennis back to business as
usual it's back to Bruce Wayne being
Bruce Wayne but like it's it's a
beautiful thing is a beautiful touching
moment because it tells us there's a
human in there somewhere and the way
that Batman's always been written is
this the pain of loss because he's
always only ever lost things he
constantly loses things all the time and
so if anything I would argue here that
in this instance and when you take this
for what it is
Batman's more of a coward it's easier to
just close himself off from humanity
than it is to accept the fact that
sometimes you just lose things that
that's just the way the world works that
as you get older things get taken from
you it's just how it happens and there's
nothing you can really do about it and
so it's it's a great thing here so it's
just great storytelling it's incredibly
good storytelling here because following
this this you know experience with Bruce
and and Dick Grayson here with Bruce
opening up to dick and saying look like
I lost my parents we should talk about
this Dick Grayson begins to open up to
Bruce Wayne and in doing so Bruce Wayne
begins to take him under his wing so
that he will become Robin it is so cool
it's just it's just damn good
storytelling and and the Batman comics
need this every once in a while anyways
well you gotta break away from like the
end of times the death of some character
Gotham is a nightmare and everything is
in terrible shape you got to move away
from that and you got to go through and
you got to tell stories periodically to
say hey things aren't necessarily that
bad all is hot sometimes they're pretty
good but let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section I'm kind of
curious to see what kind of answers you
guys give because you guys offer some
really insightful conversation when you
want to but without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core
you enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you